il y a plusieurs fois des gens qui sont
venus cagouler et armés chez mes parents
c'est c'est enfin moi je le sais je sais
c'est plusieurs fois arrivé il y a
plusieurs fois des voitures qui font la
ronde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dessus de jeunes Tic-Toc Benjamin Lady
gay Queen Paul ont voulu faire le buzz
en se déhanchant en crop top dans une
église
par contre millions de vues la vidéo oui
40 millions de vues on va la revoir sans
le récap merci Benjamin d'être avec nous
influenceur et merci Alexandre Bigot
vous êtes l'avocat de Benjamin non on
était tous les deux avec mon ami dans la
commune il a passé devant une église et
ouais je pense qu'on avait besoin de je
pense vous voulez rigoler tous les deux
il y avait pas de préparation ou les
rigoler faire cette vidéo dans les
rigoler il y avait pas de message
derrière de base c'était même pas on la
poste de base c'était juste on va on va
dans l'église on fait la vidéo c'était
super léger c'était seul dans on était
seul il y avait pas la musique je
voulais surtout dénoncer l'homophobie
qui était jusqu'à présent dans la
l'église d'accord
témoigner un moment pour autre chose
vous reviendrez certainement nous en
parler parce que c'est c'est
triste sujet c'est juste touché par ce
garçon parce que il faut comprendre
quelque chose c'est que bien sûr c'est
extrêmement choquant mais derrière tout
ça et derrière de deux gamins qu'on peut
peut-être fait une bêtise il y a un
petit message à entendre qui est bien
sûr de ne pas critiquer l'Église
catholique jamais de la vie mais qui est
que comme vous dire que moi je suis
catholique et comme ce garçon j'ai la
même sexualité pendant jusqu'à la
profession de foi pendant 15 ans on vous
dit tous les jours tous les jours quatre
homosexuels c'est mal que vous êtes
rejeté que vous ne serez pas dans la
maison de Dieu qui vous fermera la porte
que vous ne pourrez jamais vous marier à
l'époque c'est tout ce que vous entendez
et pendant 15 20 ans vous dit tu es
quelqu'un de mal tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps alors ça avance un
petit peu ça avance doucement moi il m'a
fallu à peu près 40 ans pour accepter
l'effet de catholique donc oui ils sont
jeunes je trouve très touchant ce garçon
alors bien sûr c'est très maladroit il
dit qu'il y a des substances tout ça
mais je pense qu'il faut peut-être aller
un petit peu au-delà je pense que vous
ne rendez mais alors absolument pas
service à votre communauté le message il
est entièrement faussé vraiment c'est
c'est raté excusez-moi mais c'est
vraiment raté si un message et j'en suis
même pas sûr parce que quand on voit
votre aide avec lui sur les avec les
gens en plus les gens qui vous aiment
bien
alors
[Musique]
toutes les personnes que j'ai publié je
m'en suis pas rendu compte sur le coup
je me corrigerai à l'avenir pour devenir
personne Benjamin vous a tué par 400000
personnes votre compte a été désactivé
suite à cette vidéo vous n'êtes plus
étudiant vous gagnez de l'argent en
vendant des photos de vous dénuder sur
mime c'est ça voilà on en parlera
depuis sa vidéo dans l'église il a été
menacé de mort et même de me
décapitation et ce soir il voudrait nous
parler parce que ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé chez vos
parents il y a plusieurs fois des gens
qui sont venus cagouler et armés chez
mes parents c'est enfin moi je le sais
je sais c'est plusieurs fois arrivé il y
a plusieurs fois des voitures qui font
la ronde
plusieurs fois des gens qui viennent
dans les explications à mes parents
enfin oui ça arrive tous les jours parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est que je suis venu aujourd'hui seul
pour être le premier sincère le plus
honnête et le plus indépendant possible
et je vais aussi revenir sur ce que j'ai
dit du coup il y a c'était vendredi je
suis quand je suis venu la raison pour
laquelle j'ai posté cette vidéo et que
je l'ai fait ou quoi c'était pas pour
combattre les préceptes de l'homophobie
comme j'avais dit c'était pas vrai
la vérité c'est une bêtise je l'ai fait
consciemment cette bêtise le fait qu'il
y ait des gens qui viennent chez mes
parents le fait que des gens qui me
suivent dans la rue le fait qu'il y a
des gens qui veulent me tuer
comme vous l'avez été
d'accord
et avoir défendu son OK comme vous
l'avez fait vous c'est défendre le fait
que oui on doit tuer quelqu'un dans la
rue toi tu vas pas nous faire la morale
non plus peut-être quand même
manger en plus
ça veut dire que pour nous ça nous peine
moi c'est de la peine que j'ai reçu ça
me fait du mal de voir ça franchement
c'est comme si j'allais non tais-toi
c'est comme si j'allais dans un lieu que
j'allais je sais pas dans ta chambre
d'enfance ou sur la tombe d'un de tes
proches etc et que je faisais un truc
comme ça
alors si ça était dans une agonne sur
une mosquée ça m'aurait plus mis en
colère pour le coup parce que ça
m'aurait moins peiné parce que forcément
c'est moins un sacré pour moi mais par
contre j'aurais trouvé ça dégueulasse
tout autant je dis c'est pas nous de
faire ça je pense que il y a beaucoup de
Français qui pensent qu'en fait il y a
juste ton père qui devrait te mettre une
tarte et te dire arrête de d'endiner il
va travailler parce qu'en gros c'est ça
là on est en train de parler et des
millions de Français je suis en train de
parler d'un truc en fait c'est une
connerie de gamins qui qui qui a rien
dans le cerveau mais maintenant il faut
pas que ça oui mais maintenant là on est
en train d'inverser le truc en disant le
pot c'est une victime il est la moyenne
etc excuse-moi Daniel mais moi j'étais
super choquée parce que moi je suis
croyante aussi comme toi et moi ces
images je m'en fous que ça me choque ou
pas en fait il faut pas mettre la
religion c'est pas c'est pas sacré c'est
pas au-dessus tout la religion c'est la
religion c'est à se faire intime cette
affaire privée tu vas pas aller dans une
église parce qu'il a mis un crop top et
tu vas dire oh là là quelle horreur il a
mis dans un crop top il a mis un crop
top c'est dégueulasse non en fait on
s'en fout ta religion c'est un truc
privé c'est un truc intime moi ça va pas
ébranler ma foi ou pas ma foi donc je
trouve que aujourd'hui en faisant ça on
s'attend qu'à en s'attaquant à Benjamin
finalement on le fragilise et je pense
que ça montre que justement aujourd'hui
notre société elle est pourrie parce
qu'on donne justement la parole aux
intégristes j'arrive difficilement à
concevoir qu'on puisse être blessé parce
que moi j'ai dansé dans une église enfin
j'ai 18 ans enfin
dans votre église et continuer à croire
en ce que vous croyez je trouve ça
génial et c'est hyper bien défendez-le
comme vous le défendez j'ai fait de la
merde enfin franchement c'est pas
votre vie
le problème c'est que mais en fait c'est
toujours la même chose c'est comme si
j'avais sur la tombe d'un de vos proches
que je dansais dessus je faisais du
twerk et que quand vous me disiez que ça
vous plaît je dirais bah ça fragile
c'est pas votre deuil et bien sûr ça
vous ferait du mal c'est évident c'est
un lieu secret pour nous
l'exemple de Baptiste que tu regrettes
est-ce que tu est-ce que si aujourd'hui
non je regarde pas je regarde pas
pourquoi tu refais la même vidéo si on
Si tu savais tout ce qui se passait
derrière tu refais la même vidéo
vraiment c'est à dire que là là on te
dit voilà il va se passer tout ça
derrière tu referais la même vidéo tu as
aucun regret
[Musique]
en crop top dans une église a voulu
réitérer
cette fois-ci c'est dans une mosquée
qu'il a imaginé faire sa vidéo
aujourd'hui je vais partir à la
recherche d'une mosquée à Paris manque
de chance ou de culture le jeune homme
s'est en réalité rendu devant l'église
orthodoxe de la Sainte Trinité à Paris
ok j'ai trouvé une mosquée c'est fermé
j'arriverai à comprendre au planning le
lieu est enfermé Benjamin rebroussé
chemin et les internautes ne sont pas
restés indifférents face à cette
nouvelle tentative de provocation parce
que je fais pas partie de
tu veux la paix taquette excusée
je suis c'est comme la posture dans
laquelle on m'a toujours mis sur ce
plateau ou dans les médias ou sur les
réseaux j'ai toujours été dans la
posture de de l'accusé de celui qui
avait fait quelque chose de mal de celui
qui avait commis un crime et je pense
pas que j'en ai commis et je pense que
j'ai plus envie de
de la demande enfin je demande perdu ma
personne je demande pas enfin vous
voulez continuer à provoquer
je pense pas que c'est des provocations
directes mais je reviens pas en arrière
et cherche pas à oublier non Momo par
respect je vous laisse la parole d'abord
à la baie d'accord
moi je suis venu pour chercher à
comprendre voilà comme nous comme nous
c'est exactement ça pourquoi que
fonctionnent comme ça tu as des comptes
à régler
benjaminé je suis plutôt dans le
pourquoi pas être pourquoi pas non mais
ouais c'est ce que je revendique c'est
ouais le droit au blasphème
des croyances des gens ou de leur
religion mais les considérant en tant
que personne
s'arrête là où bah oui c'est et Momo toi
ça t'a dérangé forcément je suis choqué
que ça soit dans une église une
synagogue ou dans une mosquée forcément
ça me choque autant de croyant parce que
je sais que derrière tout ça il y a des
croyants ça peut aussi heurter des
millions voir des milliers de personnes
qu'est-ce que tu as à lui dire ce soir
non Benjamin moi j'ai juste envie de lui
dire c'est un discours de grand frère
que j'ai envie de l'avoir avec lui c'est
pas un discours de c'est pas un discours
de de
peut-être mettre une baffe ou quoi ou
quoi non il faut que tu saches un truc
il faut que tu saches faut que tu saches
un truc Benjamin si tu veux visiter le
mosquée tu es toujours le bienvenu tu
seras toujours le bienvenu mais il y a
des règles à respecter il faut de la
pudeur du respect et l'humilité tu vois
si tu arrives à avoir ces trois qualités
en toi viens je te prends la main on y
va tous les deux et c'est pas forcément
ce que tu vois à la télé les musulman
il s'en fout de la vie des gens ils s'en
fout du respect de la religion et il
s'en fout de tout en fait
quand vous êtes sur les réseaux sociaux
vous incarnez un personnage qui est
constamment dans la provocation quand
vous venez sur ce plateau c'est pour
pleurniche parce que le vendredi
[Applaudissements]
donc j'ai une question est-ce que vous
avez pas l'impression de prendre
la question
à personne je l'ai dit j'en avais juste
rien à [ __ ] de la religion oh et c'est
faible j'ai le droit
il raconte n'importe quoi il arrête pas
de mentir c'est un
c'est tout simplement un petit con et
c'est insupportable
je panique la violence évidemment je
suis tellement désolé pour vos parents
de séparer l'un de l'autre mais non je
suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
gentil politiquement correct depuis le
début qu'on reçoit tout le monde a été
délicieux correct
le lendemain il recommence et vas-y
vas-y ça va vous allez y aller dans une
mosquée
la première fois et effectivement là je
pense qu'on a créé un monstre mais sauf
que effectivement tu es content en fait
parce que ça entretient le monstre en
fait et le monstre se goinfre et se
nourrit de ce qu'il est en train de
créer et en fait moi j'ai peur pour toi
parce que je pense que tu es
complètement perdu tu es complètement
perdition tu es en dangereux non mais je
le pense moi comme une maman tu as l'âge
de mon fils donc je me permets de te le
dire pardon mais à chaque fois tu remets
une pièce dans la machine et à chaque
fois tu reviens sur TPMP à chaque fois
tu dis quelque chose de différent et à
chaque fois tu trognis tu dis d'abord
c'est du cynisme après c'est l'ironie
après c'est autre chose en fait tu es
complètement poney là je vous le dis
avec tout mon coeur faites attention à
vous quoi arrêtez pour vous protéger
pour vous protéger alors il y a des gens
qui disent sur les réseaux marché qu'on
lui donne de la force en l'invitant
qu'est-ce que vous avez à répondre à ça
Géraldine mais j'ai dit qu'on avait créé
un monstre et on est en partie tout ça
ce système hein je sais pas si on lui
donne de la force et moi je suis choqué
qu'au bout de quatre émissions sur
Benjamin il y a encore des gens comme
Gilles qui tombent dans le panneau et
qui arrive à le défendre là il s'est
fait comprendre
à Bernard Montiel il pleurniche en
disant je vais recevoir des menaces
demain il va faire une vidéo histoire
devant Bernard Montiel c'est c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est avec nous je suis à la parole
influenceur est proche de Benjamin le
nid que c'est lui qui avait fait la
première vidéo avec Benjamin League dans
l'église cette vidéo qui nous a
énormément choqué mais qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont ils ont dit quoi vos parents quand
ils ont vu cette vidéo mes parents bah
comme toute personne sur un de la vidéo
ont été surpris et choqués
et j'ai quand même la chance d'avoir des
parents là pour moi et qui m'ont soutenu
comme d'ailleurs beaucoup d'amis
pendant un long moment faut savoir que
j'ai été j'ai coupé tous mes réseaux
tous mes contacts parce que j'ai
vraiment besoin de voir de rien voir
quand je vais tous les jours sur Twitter
tous les applications ma tête bateau de
Benjamin partout j'en pouvais plus et
depuis plus de nouvelles de lui il m'a
demandé un petit SMS par rapport à au
sms que j'avais envoyé par rapport enfin
les supprimer la vidéo et il m'avait
clairement dit que pour lui c'était
normal que il savait ce qu'il faisait
donc voilà et ben c'est une nouvelle
Matthieu vous comprenez qu'on invite
plus Benjamin bah évidemment mais
surtout parce que au milieu de tout ça
évidemment je suis très choqué parce
qu'il a fait mais je suis inquiet pour
lui aujourd'hui vraiment vraiment ce que
je pense que ça va mal se terminer et
j'espère vraiment pas que ça va se
terminer parce qu'il a 18 ans et que
c'est un gamin mais là la vidéo
effectivement c'est bien qu'on la montre
pas j'ai été extrêmement choqué et là il
va dans un niveau de violence et
d'insultes qui fait que pour lui à moins
de sortir de l'église déjà c'était une
admissible par exemple on a dit on
parlait du blasphème alors moi non c'est
pas politique ça existe mais je suis
contre tout ça et tu peux pas dire ça
non plus
mais je suis con l'utilisation pour
blesser les gens qui veut dire que tu as
été instrumentalisé ta vidéo était
instrumentalisée à des fins politiques
c'est-à-dire que c'est positionné par
rapport au blasphème est-ce qu'on a
voilà vous avez aucune attention
pas forcément mais blessé non
franchement j'étais inconscience jour là
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je
tenais vraiment à
tout le monde devant la caméra et c'est
plaisir de faire aujourd'hui ici de
demander le pardon parce que ça je
trouve ça important et puis
vous connaissez Benjamin un peu mieux
que nous quand même selon vous c'est
quoi son but est juste quoi
alors comme je disais je te connais oui
et non je fréquenté bien sûr
clairement c'est quelqu'un qui vit qui
sale et tout à Paris et
je pense que clairement il est perdu je
sais pas ce qu'il veut donner comme
image en tout cas moi ça au début moi
quand je vois cette vidéo qui fait
actuellement honnêtement
du dégoût et ce qui cherche je pense
c'est que il a besoin d'attention c'est
quelqu'un qui est dans l'attention et
quand je vois tous ces personnes qui
réagissent tout le temps par rapport au
Benjamin ces vidéos qui fait tous les
jours mais j'ai dit mais attends il y a
encore des gens qui réagissent à tous
les jours certes il faut réagir c'est
choquant mais c'est son jeu en fait il a
compris le petit jeu qui faisait voilà
moi j'aime bien son comportement parce
qu'il vient il se tu te dis c'est fini
moi je veux pas être avec lui tu viens
et tu demandes pardon et tu vas voir
quand tu dis ouais machin il faut pas
trop je te trouve un peu dur avec avec
lui c'est vachement bien ce que tu as
fait là parce qu'il faut pas rester à
côté d'un mec comme ça parce que ce mec
là il va il va mettre ta vie en danger
faut pas traîner avec un mec comme ça
parce que là il est en train de se
mettre en danger pour moi qu'il est très
malade et il se met en danger après tu
es venu ce soir on parle de lui et là où
je rejoins Gilles parce qu'on dit il
faut pas l'inviter il aurait dû
l'inviter j'ai dit on aurait dû
l'inviter si là il vient pour son droit
de réponse c'est très bien maintenant je
ne veux plus qu'on parle de lui moi je
veux faire comme tout à l'heure je veux
qu'on l'a on l'enlève des réseaux
sociaux bah oui mais là on fait des
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]